Why so serious? Because this fan-favorite
performance in "John Wick: Chapter 4" was
channeling none other than
Heath Ledger – no kidding.
The fourth "John Wick" movie has blown
away the box office and earned some of
the best reviews of the entire franchise. While
a lot of praise rightfully goes toward the lead
Keanu Reeves and director Chad Stahelski, the film
introduces many exciting new characters that could
easily spin off into their own franchises,
including The Tracker, a.k.a. Mr. Nobody.
True to his name, Mr. Nobody is a blank-slate
bounty hunter who's only interested in taking
out John Wick if he can get as much money
out of it as possible. He aligns himself
with various forces throughout the
movie, along with his trusted canine,
putting him in a very interesting position
by the end of the film. And there are many
directions he can go because there's still
a lot the audience doesn't know about him.
That's intentional, and actor Shamier Anderson
looked toward another mysterious antagonist for
inspiration — Heath Ledger's Joker in
"The Dark Knight." As he told Vulture,
"I looked at the Joker and studied a lot of what
Heath Ledger did, how exciting that character was;
you just knew that guy had a robust past.
Like, Why did he get those scars? And, for me,
Why do I have this canine? Why do I have
this knapsack? Why am I dressed like this?"
The result is a thrilling new character that
should absolutely get more time on the big screen.
When an actor's trying to build
a bad guy from the ground up,
drawing inspiration from one of the best movie
villains of all time is an excellent place
to start. There's also much the audience
doesn't know about Heath Ledger's Joker,
and that makes him all the more terrifying.
Shamier Anderson took what was accessible
about his character and fleshed him
out from there, going on to state,
"This guy's transient. He has
pockets because he travels so much;
he doesn't really change. That notebook you
see in the film, I took that home and wrote
a lot in there. That knapsack that he had on,
I had a lot of personal items, like dog toys,
dog treats, lighters engraved with my
name. I just had to put my DNA on this."
The part about writing in the notebook
seen in the film is an interesting parallel
to Heath Ledger's preparation to play Joker. The
actor infamously kept a diary to jot down his
character's villainous thoughts during production,
including lines of dialogue he had in the film.
"You look nervous. Is it the
scars? Wanna know how I got 'em?"
All of Anderson's hard work appears to have
paid off. He concluded his comments by saying,
"I think it's translating as people
are infatuated with the Tracker."
In a film like "John Wick: Chapter
4," which has many highlights,
being one of the best parts is definitely a
compliment and a testament to Anderson's talents.
He may have channeled Heath Ledger's Joker
for inspiration in "John Wick: Chapter 4,"
but Anderson is also a fan of another actor who
played a villain in the "Dark Knight" franchise.
In that same interview with Vulture, Anderson
said that he'd love to star in a Mr. Nobody
spinoff with Liam Neeson — who played Ra's Al Ghul
in "Batman Begins" and "The Dark Knight Rises."
And he's not the only performer Anderson
would be interested in walking the boards
with. Speaking of people he'd love
to go up against in movies, he said,
"Liam Neeson would be a great antagonist.
I think Denzel Washington would be a crazy
antagonist. It would be really interesting to see
a female villain; Meryl Streep would be something
different. So those are my top three choices:
Denzel Washington, Liam Neeson, and Meryl Streep."
It remains to be seen if Mr. Nobody will
ever get his own spin-off. In the meantime,
fans can look forward to returning
to the "John Wick" universe via "The
Continental" and "Ballerina"
spin-offs in the near future.